江田）おはようございます
一同）おはようございます
江田）本日光ドロップを担当させていただきます
江田）江田です　よろしくお願いします
高本）火ドロップ担当高本(たかぽん)です　よろしくお願いします
青嶋）水ドロップ担当青嶋です　よろしくお願いします
棚沢）木ドロップ担当棚沢です　よろしくお願いします
セバスチャン）闇ドロップ担当セバスチャンです　よろしくお願いします
江田）本日の落ちコンは
江田）わたくし、光ドロップ担当が
江田）仕切らせていただきます　よろしくお願いします
一同）よろしくお願いします
江田）我々が今回落とすドロップはあちらに置いてあります
江田）我々で
江田）1コンボでも多く
江田）落ちコンボで
江田）コンボを繋げていきましょう
一同）はい
江田）作業にかかれ！
たかし）ただいまー
たかし）おいババァーめしー
たかし）ふっざけんなよあのセンコウ
たかし）俺のことバカにしやがってよー
たかし）んだよ宿題1週間忘れただけで
たかし）お前学校来んなってナメてんのかよ　チッ
たかし）はぁー　チッ
たかし）はぁパズドラすっか
江田）ハッ
江田）全員集合
一同）はい
江田）大変です、早速プレイヤーがパズルを始めました
江田）皆さんは落ちコンの準備にかかってください
一同）はい
江田）皆んな準備はできたか？
たかし）お！ゼウスのダンジョンあんじゃん
たかし）うぉーい うぃーゼウスのダンジョンいこーっと
江田）始まったぞ
たかし）あ
江田）水ドロップ！
江田）左から2列目　青嶋）はい
たかし）水こい！ うっし！
一同）おおおー
江田）すごい　高本）ナイスナイス
江田）素晴らしいありがとうございます
たかし）っしゃー
たかし）やべぇ今日落ちコンきてんな
たかし）っしゃーバトル2いくぜー
江田）あっもうバトル２が始まりますよ
一同）頑張れ　頑張れ　いいぞー
たかし）あ、やべ　あ、やべ
たかし）はい、落ちコン　落ちコン　ほいっ
棚沢）あ、あぁ
棚沢）2個繋がってるところがない！
江田）まずい…
江田）闇ドロップ左から2,3,4列目
セバスチャン）了解しました
江田）まだいける、木ドロップ左3列目
棚沢）はい
江田）水ドロップ　青嶋）はい
江田）火ドロップ　高本）はい
江田）お、おお！　すごい
セバスチャン）やったー
たかし）こんなんバトル2でくんなよ
たかし）ふざけんなよ落ちコン
江田）すごい　さすが　素晴らしい　素晴らしい
セバスチャン）すごい上手い
たかし）っしゃーバトル3いくぜ
江田）バトル3ですよ
たかし）あ、やべ　あ、やべ
たかし）あ、やべ　やべ
たかし）あ、やべ回復、おい回復
(江田:え、待って)
たかし）落ちコン！回復来い
江田）回復！回復、回復です、回復の人！
セバスチャン）回復、回復誰？回復誰!?
棚沢）回復今日休みです
江田）はぁ？　高本）え？
セバスチャン）行けよ行けよいけよ
青嶋）え？俺じゃない
江田）行けよ　回復行けよ
一同）行けよ　違う　行け
(江田:回復行けよ)
(一同:行けよ行けよ)
たかし）おぉーい
江田）あっ、お、あぁ勝てたぁ
江田）勝てた　一同）うわあああああい
たかし）良かったぁ　ババァ勝てたー
(一同:わあああああああ)
一同）あああああい
江田）バト、バトル4ですよ
たかし）しっくぜー
江田）まだ気を抜くのは早いですよ　ここからです
たかし）あ、やべ　　あ…
たかし）あっ…あ、やべ
江田）落ちコンを読み取るのです
(たかし:あ、やべ　やべ)
たかし）あ、やべ　闇！闇の落ちコン闇のコン
江田）闇ドロップー左1列目ー
セバスチャン）左1列目　はい
セバスチャン）あぁ！
たかし）しぃぃぃぃっしゃー
江田）すごい
セバスチャン）やったー
江田）すごすきる
江田）素晴らしい
たかし）っしゃーナイス落ちコン　センキュー
江田）あなたは天才ですか
セバスチャン）ありがとうございます
江田）素晴らしい
セバスチャン）なんとかできました
江田）まさか火まで入れるとは
たかし）っしゃー
たかし）え？これいけるんじゃね？ゼウス
江田）情報によれば次がラストバトル
江田）ゼウスです
たかし）あ、やっば　ラストはやっべゼウスだ
たかし）やっべー俺パスドラ…やっべーゼウスだ
たかし）うわ、やっっっっば
江田）頼む頑張ってくれ
たかし）やべっ
たかし）あっ　あっ　あ、やべ
たかし）あ、やべっ　ちょっと違う　やべ
たかし）やべ　あ、やべ　やべ　うわマジやべぇ
たかし）あ、やばい　うわぁ
青嶋）はっ闇！
青嶋）闇だ　江田）闇だ
一同）闇だ　早く　闇　早く
セバスチャン）ああああ
江田･高本･棚沢･青嶋）ああーーーーーー
たかし）ふざけんなよ
たかし）なんでだよ
セバスチャン）はーはｗすいません
江田）何やってんすか
一同）おいおいおい　あーー　もう
江田）負けたんすよ今ので
セバスチャン）すいませんでした
たかし）なんで負けるんだあああああ
たかし）なんでだあああああああ
セバスチャン）ほんとすいません
青嶋）だからもう
江田）1回しかないんすよ
セバスチャン）ごめんなさい
青嶋）ちゃんとパズル見ろよ
江田）今ので負けましたから
たかし）なんで勝てねぇんだよ
たかし）あああああ、あああああ
たかし）かぁーさーん
たかし）課金していい？
棚沢）あーーーーーー
青嶋）しっかりしろよ
セバスチャン）わざとじゃないです
青嶋）ないわほんと　もうありえない
棚沢）あーーーーー　高本）最悪
高本）もいうちょいちょっと
青嶋）どうするんすか？
一同）うわあああああああああ
江田）課金はいりました
一同）ありがとうございまーす
一同）やったああああ　うわあああああ
一同）Fooooo
たかし）まぁワンコンティニューくらいならいいっしょ
江田）よし、課金がはりました　一同）はい
江田）コンティニューです　一同）はい
江田）これでゼウス倒しましょう　一同）はーい
たかし）よしこれで絶対倒す
たかし）あっ　あ　あ、やべ
たかし）あ、やべ　あ、やべ
江田）水と火！　青嶋･高本）はい
江田）水は右1列目　青嶋）はい
江田）火は右3列目下から2番目　高本）はい
江田）緑右1列目　棚沢）はい
たかし）はいっ　はい！
たかし）っしゃーーーーーーー
たかし）勝ったあああああああああああ
(江田:勝ったああああああああ)
江田）勝ったあああああ
セバスチャン）いええええええええい
たかし）ママーーーーーーー
(一同:やったあああ　勝ったあああ)
たかし）勝ったよーーーーー！
(一同:よっしあああ　勝った)
一同）ばんざーい　ばんざーい　ばんざーい
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】